another infrastructure disaster in
America one person is dead after a
section of busy highway collapse in
Philly after a tanker truck carrying
flammable cargo exploded beneath an I-95
overpass there officials predict that
the road will be closed for months and
that is setting off a wave of traffic
nightmares Transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge pledging to give whatever
resources are needed to rebuild
the entire region affected by this will
have the full support of the United
States Department of Transportation for
as long as it takes to get that restored
to normal It's a cruel reminder of the
importance of our infrastructure but we
have been surrounded by reminders of the
importance of our infrastructure which
is why we're coming together at such an
important moment that little speech
reminded me of another one that we play
on this by another person in the
administration the latest disaster has
some calling into question Buddha judges
obsession with Equity over actually
fixing America's crumbling
infrastructure the transportation
secretary launching a one billion dollar
pilot to build racial Equity into roads
and has spoken in the past about how
construction workers are not diverse
enough
there's an extraordinary opportunity
right now to make sure that more women
and workers of color are entering the
Building Trades when you're moving a
trillion dollars through the economy
about half of which is for
transportation those proportions are so
great that if we do it right you should
be able to look back at the 2020s later
on and say the right choices were made
around infrastructure spending Jesse it
is something to see infrastructure like
that crumble and we know that we need to
do things for infrastructure this is
going to cause a huge amount of problems
in that area for months well that was a
racist
Highway that deserves to die an ugly
death I can't believe you guys are
piling on mayor Pete it's not mayor
Pete's fault this tanker crash Dana try
to be a little fair you know we take a
lot of shots around this table at
politicians and I admit I've
participated in some of this
partisanship but this is a moment where
we need to say this was just an accident
and these things happen and if you think
this is an artificial stance you are
dead wrong you are dead wrong people
died we shouldn't be politicizing this
maybe this will take 45 years to fix
because you have to grease all the right
people in Philadelphia fine but it's
important that we realize that this was
a racist Highway and these things happen
is that right Harold
well I think part of what Jesse's saying
is is right that I think I say this a
lot but I think two things can be right
we need more equity in things but we
need to fix things you think about what
happened I thought the judge I didn't
give her credit I gave her credit after
this show I texted her you talked last
week about uh East Palestine and how
we've kind of forgotten that in our
narrative the people there have not and
not to say that all the local
politicians have but it's not part of
the national dialogue we talked on this
show when that happened we needed an
inventory to be taken of how many
Railways around the country may have
similar challenges as those is that that
those Railways there
it would be it would behoove the
secretary and perhaps they have this
information and we should be sharing it
are there other bridges are there other
other parts of I-95 that made me
vulnerable to collapse with an
overheating and it's terrible what
happened underneath the bridge
underneath the passageway that made this
happen these are the things that
politicians should be focused on you're
right in one regard this was an accident
into uh you can't to try to blame
something other than it being an
accident but I think where you really
blame people is if they don't begin to
think
forwardly about what can we do to ensure
that something like this doesn't happen
again and that's that's when I don't
hear enough in politics that's why I was
pleased to see Governor Newsom say what
he said about the homelessness issue in
crime is she owned it we got to own
these challenges and figure out how more
importantly how we fix them what do you
think judge well I think that I know
that Pennsylvania got 11.3 billion
dollars for Highway work uh and that 51
percent of uh Pennsylvania roads are
considered poor there's no secret that
work needs to be done in addition to
that apparently the American Society for
civil engineers gave Pennsylvania a d I
think it's a minus for their Bridges and
Roads so the question that I have is
after this truck had an accident where
petroleum-based product blew up and
there was a fire and the bridge came
down is anyone surprised I mean we
already know the roads are poor and we
only already know that the civil
engineers have said they're poor we
already know Pennsylvania got 11 billion
dollars for roads and infrastructure and
then they're going to give Pennsylvania
another 6 million dollars uh according
to Buddha judge that they need why do
they need another 6 million when they
got 11.3 billion dollars and let's talk
about the fact that this is going to
take forever there's 160 000 people a
day who travel on this I-95 well let's
compare if we want to compare is a
Newsome so great at this Apparently
after Hurricane Ian in Florida Pine
Island Bridge collapse in Florida and
Governor DeSantis fixed it in four days
okay and they're going to be waiting
months that's what the Democrats do the
other thing that happens Greg we saw
this with the coven money and it's
happening in the infrastructure Bill too
which is they push money out so quickly
because they wanted we wanted to get
money out there but one of the things
that we know in looking back is that
there was not enough vetting a lot of
fraud yeah there's a lot of fraud
there's been so much fraud I don't even
believe those numbers
um
he isn't thinking forward uh to your
point Harold because he's too busy
Looking Backward
so I would not blame obviously this on
this thing on him except that he's
constantly blaming everything on racism
and that is Looking Backward instead of
forward the equity choice is impossible
with different cultures you you can't
have the same equity for everybody it's
just the way things are uh you know to
his credit he got me to look up you know
the whole point of redlining and
everything of that and the systemic
racism but every time I look up at that
I always find out the same thing and
that is that 78 or 75 percent of the
people that live in those districts
aren't black right they're just poor
yeah they're just poor so blacks rank
third in population behind um Hispanic
Latin and white I think White's number
one but because when you put it through
the prism of racism nothing gets solved
and I think that's what's happening here
with infrastructure now is that he's
really good at at playing the you know
the the uh what the media wants to hear
but he's not solving any problems so I
would say to him to get the big stuff
solved before you jabber on about
systemic racism and construction every
time there's a transportation crisis he
always seems like he's the first he's
the last person to know he never sees
anything coming except for the the
reporters then he's there but here's a
great question he mentioned it slyly
do this study please do the study on why
there are no female construction workers
come have you ever we've been on the
planet 50 some odd years have you ever
seen in New York city where the the
capital of construction a female
construction worker walking on a girl
I've never seen one do you think it has
something to do with the lack of upper
body strength no I or do you think it's
discrimination I think it's people like
you Jesse who whistle at them I call it
reverse whistling
well I mean I'm not going to say
something no dude do it because the old
Jesse would have not this just but it is
interesting isn't it that like that's
the one in Westchester not New York but
I think they're talking about are
women-owned firms yeah and they whistle
at me yes so I don't feel the need to
whistle back I'm gonna go I'm just gonna
walk out on that thing by myself and say
their biological difference what are you
wearing when they whistle at you what am
I wearing
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcaneny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 p.m Eastern or set your
DVD are also don't forget to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights